>>Male Presenter: Thanks for joining us today
for Nerd Fitness. This talk is a part of Health@Google--a
speaker series which provides Googlers with
more information on health and wellness. The
aim of Health@ is to provide Googlers with
tools and resources to make the right health
and wellness choices for themselves and their
families.
We're also still looking for wellness champions--folks
who help to shape and promote the wellness
programs at Google. You can check out goto/wellnesschampions
to find out more. To see all our upcoming
speakers and topics, visit goto/oil. Steve
Kamb is the creator of nerdfitness.com, a
fitness community and blog dedicated to helping
desk jockeys and average Joes level up their
lives.
A gamer his whole life, Steve has been focused
on strength training and exercise as a hobby
for the past ten years, as an obsession, as
an obsession for the past five years, and
as a full-time job for the past year. Currently
on his epic quest of awesomeness, a 35000
mile trip around the world, Steve has exercised
everywhere and anywhere getting in the best
shape of his life despite living out of a
backpack and never setting foot in a gym.
In between workouts, he's rock climbed in
Thailand, scuba dived the Great Barrier Reef
in Australia, sky dived in New Zealand, and
even piloted a stunt plane. Thanks for joining
us, Steve.
[applause]
>>Steve Kamb: Thanks Chad for that. Can everyone
hear me OK?
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: Yeah.
>>Steve Kamb: All right. Great. First of all,
guys, I just wanna start by saying thank you
so much for having me. Google is one of those
companies that you always hear about, but
you don't--. You always wonder what goes on
there.
So, for me today, it feels like Charlie and
The Chocolate Factory, getting to see everything
happening around the world--.
[clears throat]
Excuse me. Getting to see how this place actually
runs. So, I'm sure many of you are wondering
who I am what the heck I'm doing here. So
let's get started. This is a picture of me
as Superman, back when--I wanna say--maybe
when I was four, maybe five. To be honest
with you, I don't actually know the date.
Generally, you could say, "Oh, that's Halloween
of October 2005," or I'm sorry, Halloween
when I was five or Halloween when I was four.
But that could've been me on a Tuesday. I
just happened to like dressing up like Superman
as often as possible, because I really wanted
to be the Man of Steel. I was just fascinated
with the whole concept of being strong and
super-fast and lightening quick and all these
things.
Unfortunately, my genetics did not really
line up with being Superman. So, I'd always
been that scrawny, weak, I don't wanna say
slow, but scrawny weak kid that just never
had an opportunity to become super strong.
And normally it wasn't an issue growing up
as a kid. It's all right. It's fine. You don't
need to be strong.
And it never really caught up to me until
I got to high school and everybody else around
me had this wonderful thing happen to them
and it missed out on me. Puberty. Well, by
the time I was a sophomore in high school,
I think I was maybe five feet tall, a hundred
pounds. And then my junior year, I finally
started growing.
I was five feet tall. I'm sorry. Five feet,
ten inches tall, still a hundred pounds. Just
a total weakling. A stiff breeze would blow
me over. I really wanted to start playing
basketball. My brother played. My dad played.
All of my friends played. I had played growing
up, so I signed up for the high school basketball
team.
And actually, as a five foot ten, hundred
pound weakling, I got cut from the basketball
team. But this was the most horrifying moment
of my life. I can't believe I got cut from
this basketball team. So the very next day,
I signed up for a gym membership. I remember
this day like it happened yesterday. I went
to the gym and having no clue what I was doing,
walked upstairs to the free weight section.
I remember lying down on the bench. Like an
idiot, I loaded up 45-pound plates on each
side of the bench. And I remember lying down
on the bench, just that's what guys do. They
do bench presses. I didn't know any better.
All right. Why not? Let's get started. So
I laid down on the bench, lifted the weight
off the rack, brought it down to my chest--
[laughter]
and it got stuck there. Fortunately again,
I was stupid enough not to put any clips on
the outside of the rack. So I'm lying there
and I slowly twisted my body to the left until
that big 45-pound plate spiraled off the end
of the bar bell. Boom! Smack down on the ground.
As soon as that one hit, the whole weight
shifted to the other side. Boom! That one
fell down on the ground. I'm lying there on
the bench. OK. It's OK. Maybe nobody saw this.
So I quickly put the weight back, the bar
bell back on the rack. And I sat up. And I
looked as those 45-pound weights were rolling
across the gym floor and about 40 pairs of
eyes were just staring at me, like "Who is
this kid and what is he doing in a gym?"
I thought the basketball cutting was getting
the most mortified area of my life. Nope.
It was that day, in that gym. But I realized
something. Like, you know what? OK. There's
a start here. I obviously can't get any worse
than what I just did. I can build from this.
There's something that I can do.
So from that point on, I made a commitment
to myself saying, "You know what? I wanna
get stronger. I don't wanna be weak. I don't
wanna be that skinny kid. I wanna start making
some changes in my life." So I spent two years,
the last two years of my high school strength
training. I spent four years of college strength
training, desperately trying to get stronger.
I read every muscle and fitness magazine,
'cause that's what you're supposed to do if
you wanna get in shape, right? I started drinking
protein shakes, 'cause that's what you're
supposed to do. Didn't help. Through four
years of college, I think I put on maybe two
pounds. Just a complete, I'm not gonna say
waste of my time, 'cause I learned so much
in that time.
But I realized in those six years, I really
hadn't accomplished much. At this point after
graduating, I moved out to California. Got
a desk job in sales and signed up for a gym
membership. And fortunately, they gave me
five free personal trainer sessions. Something
I had never had before, something I didn't
think I needed.
I was like, "Oh, I'll be fine. I don't need
a trainer. I'd been exercising for six years."
Well, I sat down with that trainer, who completely
changed how I ate and how I exercised. And
I'll tell you, in those first 28 days, I had
more progress than I did in the entire six
years prior of training. From that point,
I was addicted.
And I knew it. It's like, "I got it." From
that point, I just started reading everything
I could about fitness. I wanted to be--. I
was like, OK. If I made six years of mistakes
and I've finally seen the light, there have
to be other people out there like me who don't
know who to talk to, who don't know where
to turn, maybe don't have the money for a
personal trainer, but they wanna start getting
in shape.
So I started formulating this idea of a community
of folks that would help other people get
started on that path to getting in shape.
It was actually right around this time that
a movie by the name of "300" came out. This
was back in 2007. And I'm sure most of you
guys have seen this movie. It may be not the
deepest plot in the world, or the deepest
characters, but damn, those dudes were in
shape.
And I couldn't help but get inspired watching
these guys and thinking here are actors getting
paid millions of dollars and they dedicated
their lives for months and months and months
and months and months to get in the best shape
of their lives. So I started doing some research
how they got in shape.
What did they do? And I came across this quote
from Mark Twight, who is the trainer of all
the actors from the movie, "300." And that
quote is "appearance is a consequence of fitness."
And that really, really resonated with me.
It made sense. I said, "OK." For me, I wanted
to get bigger and stronger. For many other
people, they needed to lose weight and maybe
get a little bit stronger.
And this concept really fascinated me. OK,
if you wanna look better on the outside that's
quite all right. Put your focus into becoming
the best athlete or getting in the best shape
of your life if you can and your appearance
will follow. So, I started building the concept
of Nerd Fitness around that. So that's how
it happened, how I decided on the whole concept
of Nerd Fitness.
It's actually really pretty simple. I had
this idea from "300". I had been training,
from that point, probably eight years in a
gym--two years pretty seriously. I was like,
"Well, I'm kind of a nerd. I like fitness.
Stick 'em together." I looked it up. Couldn't
find any online for a community of folks that
worked at a desk job that wanted to get in
shape.
And I realized that I had been making mistakes
for the majority of my life trying to exercise.
There had to be other people out there like
that. And as far as exercise goes, it's not
like in a video game. You always start on
that first level where everything is really
easy. They hold your hand and walk you through
it. In fitness, you're thrown to the sharks.
You walk into a gym. There's a million elliptical
machines, a bunch of exercise machines, free
weights with huge dudes standing. It's really
intimidating. And that stuff used to intimidate
me, but it didn't anymore. And I thought I
had an opportunity to help people that were
in my same position maybe six years prior
to start getting in shape.
So I come to you today not as a fitness expert.
I don't claim to be one. I leave that to the
actual fitness experts themselves. But I come
to you as a guy that's in the trenches with
you. I spend all day on a computer, sitting
behind a desk, until recently when I booked
this crazy trip, which I'll get to in a little
bit.
But I booked this trip--. I'm sorry. I sit
behind a desk and I play video games at night,
but I also enjoy reading about fitness and
diet and health and exercise. And I want to
pass on that information to folks that don't
know where to begin who really wanna get started.
So I formulated the concept for Nerd Fitness
and broke it down to one main goal.
That's be better today than you were yesterday.
It's a simple concept. One sentence to grow
around. But I didn't think that sounded nerdy
enough. If I'm gonna run a website called
Nerd Fitness, I have to come up with a cooler,
nerdier tag-line than that. So that sentence
became, "Level up your life, every single
day."
That's a simple concept and it breaks down
into whatever aspect of fitness you're hoping
to accomplish. If you wanna be stronger, if
you can find a way to lift one more pound
today than you did last week, you're officially
stronger.
[male voice interrupting]
If you're a runner--. Sorry guys.
>>Female: Hi. If you're on VC, please make
sure to mute. We can hear you.
[male voice interrupting]
>>Steve Kamb: [chuckles] Hi guys on VC.
>>Female: OK, thanks.
>>Steve Kamb: [chuckles] Alrighty then. So
yeah. Back to the concept of leveling up your
life. It's simple. If you wanna be a better
runner, all you have to do is worry about
running one second faster, or one meter farther
than you ran last time.
And you're gonna start to make those changes.
You're gonna start improving and leveling
up your life, very similar to a video game
character. And that's something that I grasped
on to and have been running Nerd Fitness as
concept around for almost three years now.
So I wanted to break that down a little bit
more.
What are four aspects of Nerd Fitness? Four
aspects of being a nerd that you can really
rally behind and apply to your everyday life,
to actually get better at fitness. I like
to refer to those affectionately as the Four
Pillars of Nerdiness. But we'll get to these
shortly. But they come down to Zero to Hero,
Leveling Up, Achievements and Rewards, and
also Clans and Competition.
So let's take a look at that first concept,
Zero to Hero. What does Spiderman, Captain
America, and the Incredible Hulk all have
in common? They all started out as nerds,
zeros. And through some super awesome act,
became an incredible super human version of
themselves. And I always, again, as the skinny
guy, a weak guy, it's something I enjoyed
reading about and watching movies on.
It's like, "Hey, that's kinda cool. This is
a guy that used to be a nobody and suddenly
became a great, an updated version of themselves."
So obviously, until Google invents it, we
don't have any radioactive spiders that can
bite us to turn us into superheroes. So, I
wanna take a look at a different concept in
the same Zero to Hero category.
That's a game that I grew up playing, fell
in love with. I will play each one of them
until the day I die. I'm talking about "The
Legend of Zelda." And the reason I fell in
love with The Legend of Zelda is because at
the beginning of every game you're always
this scrawny, a little kid with a wooden sword
and a wooden shield and you're told you need
to go save the world.
Holy crap. That's a little intimidating. What
happens by the end of the game? You're wielding
this sweet Master Sword. You're defeating
Ganon, rescuing Zelda, saving the world. You've
done it. You've gone officially from zero
to hero--level zero to level 50 . You've been
able to accomplish something that you didn't
think was possible back at the beginning.
Sticking with that same concept. We're gonna
move on to Leveling Up here. So, my favorite
game in Zelda was always "A Link to the Past,"
way back in the Super Nintendo. I remember
playing this game actually back in 3rd grade.
My mom told me I couldn't play at once for
an entire month because I played so often
I couldn't sleep 'cause I had the music from--I
think it was--the third dungeon in the Light
World playing in my head.
I told my mom, "I can't sleep. The music's
stuck in my head." She said, "All right. Well
you're not playing anymore." Crap. Luckily,
she let me finally start playing it again.
And I realized why Zelda really appealed to
me. And it was this concept of this kid had
to go save the world with just this huge,
terrifying, overwhelming idea to him.
But he didn't worry about it. What did he
do? Link started with level one. He beat level
one, got a little bit stronger, got a new
weapon, moved on to level two. Did he have
to worry about the future? No. He moved on
to level two. As soon as he got to level two,
he can move on to level three and so on. Essentially,
to borrow a phrase from "What About Bob?"
Essentially, this poor kid was simply taking
baby steps towards saving the world and he
was able to accomplish it. The next concepts
are Achievements and Rewards. I don't know
if anybody here plays a game like World of
Warcraft, or any of those persistent online
games. I'm sure everybody has had months of
their lives sucked into these things, like
I have.
For me, I actually started playing a game
called EverQuest, which is World of Warcraft's
precursor, back in my--I wanna say--sophomore
year of high school. At the time, I had no
car, but I had a great computer and an EverQuest
install disk, which meant months of my life
were sucked into this game. And you know,
it's all virtual stuff.
You don't really--. At the end of the day,
you could spend 15 hours getting all these
really cool things, but you don't actually
accomplish anything in the real world. But
it didn't matter. You were still--. You had
this idea of constant achievements and rewards.
If you started as level one, they tell you
to go kill some rats and deliver a message
to somebody.
I'd say, "Well, why the heck am I gonna do
that?" Well, because it's gonna get you closer
to level two. As soon as you get to level
two, hey, I might a sword or I might get this
cool spell or this new attack and go to this
new zone. You get to all these really cool
things that continually escalate what you're
hoping to accomplish when it comes to--.
What you do in this game you, again, very
similar to Zelda, you get to go up from a
zero to a hero--zero to level 50, or whatever
the level cap is these days. I have no idea
because my computer broke and I couldn't play
it anymore. And last but not least, we have
Clans and Competitions. I'm sure everybody
has also played a game like Modern Warfare
2 or Halo, Half Life, Counter Strike, Team
Fortress, any of those online shooter games.
And to be honest with you, I suck at first
person shooters. I am terrible. I lived with
two kids in Atlanta for the past three years
who were great at these games. And I never
wanted to play because I knew they'd always
kick my ass. One day last year, they got Halo
Reach. They said, "Steve, c'mon man. Let's
play." "All right. I'll get into it. I'll
finally start playing Halo."
I think the first time I played, I got one
kill and I died 37 times. Not exactly a great
ratio, but I learned something. You know what?
One kill is better than zero. And next time
I went out, I got two kills and only 35 deaths.
It's like, "Well, you only got one more kill,
but hey. That's a hundred percent increase
in my kill ratio right there.
Thank you very much." So I could build on
that. And I noticed I could start not only
comparing myself against my previous stats,
but I could compare myself to people all around
the world and have these competitions and
say, "Well you know what? I got great at this.
I wasn't so good at this, but I can get better
and I can see if I'm getting better in the
right way."
So, we now have these four concepts. I wanna
think of what we can do to combine them and
actually use them to essentially level up
our lives. Here's a term I like to call "Real
Life Role-Playing," which is a little different
than the role-playing you're probably used
to at home with your wife or husband. Let's
start with that first goal.
We have a concept of going from zero to hero.
And for this, whenever anybody comes to me
and says, "Steve, I wanna get in shape," or
"I wanna get stronger. I wanna run faster,"
I encourage them to get super specific with
that goal. And by that I mean if you're gonna
be a superhero, what would your super power
be?
And the reason for that is it takes things
from the abstract and makes them tangible.
So, if somebody says, "I wanna get in shape,"
encourage them to put a date and maybe a goal
on it. And that becomes maybe lose ten percent
body fat by September 1st. You all of a sudden
have a specific goal that you can start working
towards.
Getting stronger becomes do a freaking pull-up
by Halloween. Everybody always wants to be
able to do one. They never can. And they say
they want to get stronger. In what way do
you want to get stronger? Be specific and
then you can start tailoring your work outs
and your plans around how you're gonna get
stronger.
Maybe you wanna run faster. Everybody wants
to run faster. It's, you like running? Maybe
you wanna run faster. Let's break that down.
Instead of just running faster, maybe you
wanna run a half marathon in under two hours.
Or maybe you wanna finally run a full marathon.
Whatever it is set a specific goal so that
you know exactly what your particular level
fifty is.
And by that I mean you're working your way
up slowly. Yeah, you can get into it, but
if you have that specific idea in mind, that
tangible goal that you can work towards, it
makes it a lot easier to start putting the
steps in place, which is that next level up
concept. And for this, I'm sure you've all
heard the phrase, "What gets measured gets
improved."
The reason I say that is because if you don't
know how good you did last week, how the heck
are you gonna know how good you're gonna do
this week in order to be better? And for that,
I mean it's time to track every workout you
do. And if you're not working out yet, I'll
get to this a little later on. And by that
I mean what exactly you did.
Did you do push-ups, squats? Did you do pull-ups?
Whatever you did, how many of them did you
do? How long did it take you to do it? And
how did you feel afterwards? Once you have
these things written down and kept track of,
next week you can look back at your previous
workouts and say, "OK, I got it. Last week
I did ten push-ups. In order for me to be
stronger this week, simple. I need to do 11
push-ups. If I can do 11, I am now officially
stronger."
If you’re running, maybe you ran a mile
last week and it exhausted you. OK. How long
did it take you to run that mile? If it took
you nine, nine and a half minutes, great.
If you can do it this week in nine minutes
and twenty-nine seconds, you are now officially
faster. Congratulations, you made a step in
the right direction.
On top of that, if you're really interested
in how your appearance looks, or you know
you wanna lose weight, you wanna make sure
you're losing the right kind of weight. I
wholeheartedly encourage you to keep track
of your measurements. And I don't mean measure
yourself on a daily basis. That can lead to
all kinds of mental issues.
Oh my God, my weight went up one pound or
down two, or vice versa. I mean, over the
course of a couple of weeks, keep track of
not only your body fat percentage, of which
you can use a simple caliper that you can
buy online for ten bucks to show if it's progressing
in the right direction. Also your weight.
You can even use a simple tape measure. Take
measurements like your chest, navel, waist,
hips, thigh, whatever. As long as you're measuring
the same thing in the same spot at the same
time of day each week, you can show that you're
getting healthier in the right way. Another
thing that you can also track is your diet.
I know a lot of people don't like to track
calories. For me personally, that's one of
the best things I think somebody can do the
first couple days of starting out. The majority
of people don't have any idea how much they're
actually eating. And after a couple days of
tracking that, they realize, "Oh, I was eating
way more than I thought," or maybe, "I was
eating way less than I thought."
So that's the Leveling Up concept. At this
point, I wanna introduce a good friend of
mine. I've never actually met her. She actually
lives in Boston, so I'll get a chance to meet
her in a couple of weeks. It's a girl by the
name of Staci, who has recently become a moderator
on the Nerd Fitness message boards, a community
that we have through the site.
The reason I wanna bring up Staci, or Spezzy,
as she's known on the boards, is that she
has become such an inspiration to all the
girls that read Nerd Fitness because of her
great, incredible story. So we're gonna back
up a little bit. Staci works as an email marketing
manager up in Boston. Back in August of 2009,
this is about a year before she discovered
Nerd Fitness, she weighed 172 pounds.
On top of that, she had a body fat percentage
around 35 to 37 percent, according to her
doctor. And she wanted to lose weight. So
what she started doing, we'll get to that
in a second. This is Staci at 172 pounds here
back in August of 2009. Now, what Staci did
is what every girl that generally runs across
fitness starts doing.
They start to starve themselves. They start
running six hours a day on a treadmill because
they think that's what they're supposed to
do. And Staci did this for over a year. She
worked out every single day. All she did was
run, run, run, run, run, run, run. I think
she was eating somewhere between 900 and maybe
1100 calories a day, practically starving
herself.
As a result, she got all the way down to 120
pounds as of August of 2010. As an unfortunate
side effect of that, Staci was also a twig.
She had no muscle on her. She was tired all
the time. She felt like crap. And incredibly
weak, she told me a story of how she, at this
point in her life, she actually wanted to
start weight training.
So she bought herself a Gillian Michaels DVD
and two pink, 5-pound dumbbells. And could
not actually physically lift them up to do
a chest press because she was so weak. So
from that point on, this is the point when
she discovers Nerd Fitness, hops on the message
boards and starts speaking with all the other
folks on there that are doing strength training.
And from here on over the next two months,
she was actually able to put on ten pounds
of healthy muscle. And how she did that was
honestly through strength training. And I
know a lot of girls are very hesitant. They
don't wanna get too bulky. They're, "Oh my
God, if I start lifting weights I'm gonna
start looking like some 'roided up girl that
belongs in a body weight competition and not
in a, not the look that they're going for."
Well, I'm here to tell you that's all crap.
I show you here that Staci, like I said, she
started weight training. And not only did
she start weight training, she started weight
training old school. I'm talking barbell,
big plates on the side, lifting heavy, dead
lifts, squats, overhead presses, bench press.
And it was actually right around this point
in October when she started to really get
into the whole strength training thing.
These are her stats over the past seven months
she's kept meticulous track of. The top bar
is actually her, how much she's been able
to dead lift. You notice back in October she
started at 135 pounds, and last week she actually
dead lifted 315 pounds. She weighs 140 pounds
now. So, it's about two and a half, two point
two five, two and a half times her own body
weight.
Her bench press has gone from 95 pounds up
to 135. And her overhead press has gone from
50 pounds all the way up to 95. And it's been
so cool to see this happen. So you're probably
wondering, "OK. This girl packs on an additional
ten pounds of muscle again. She's been strength
training heavy." I mean, 315 pounds is a ridiculous
amount of weight to lift. "So what happened?"
What happens to somebody that packs on more
weight, as a female, while lifting heavy?
This is her back in October at 131 pounds.
This is her taken yesterday at 142 pounds.
Believe it or not, the picture on the right,
she's actually 11 pounds heavier than the
picture on the left. How was she able to do
it? One, she tracked all of her weight.
She did every week. And honestly, I wouldn't
believe this if somebody sent me these pictures
and said, "Hey, look what I did." Because
every, honestly the internet, everybody is
skeptical. However, she's been keeping track
of every one of her workouts for the past
seven months on the Nerd Fitness message boards.
You go back through there and read the archives
and see on this day she lifted this much.
She did these exercises. She weighed in at
this amount of weight. This is awesome to
see what she's been able to accomplish simply
because she knew what she wanted, she put
her focus on getting stronger. And as a result,
her appearance started to show that.
Now let's move on to that Achievements and
Rewards category. And this is very similar
to what I was just discussing. But I want
you to always show progress. And by that I
mean, if you're keeping track of your stats.
It's really easy for you to see, OK. If I
did this last week, I need to do this, this
week in order to start seeing some success.
On top of that, I highly encourage people--and
this is one that drives me absolutely crazy--I
see people go to a gym and they start lifting
weights. And they take a class and they do
some sort of cardio aerobic class and they
come home and stuff their face with a 300-calorie
Gatorade and a piece of cake because they've
earned it because they worked out.
They've actually done more damage with the
food that they ate compared to the amount
of exercise that they have actually been able
to do. For that, I encourage you to reward
yourself with things that reward you back.
And by that, I mean if you are--. If you wanna
lose weight, say, by the time I get to 50
pounds loss, I'm gonna buy myself some new
clothes.
That will encourage you to wanna lift, encourage
you to want to continue to be better. Let's
say maybe you want to take a karate class.
You say, "OK, great. I will take that karate
class after I've exercised three days a week
for two months in a row." So that you have
the confidence to walk into that class. You
have these things that you can build on and
reward yourself with to give you things to
look forward to.
Not only look forward to them, but look forward
to them and use those things to even get better
and better and better. At this point, I wanna
introduce you to another guy that came across
my site back in October of 2010. His name
is Tony. Back in October, Tony weighed in
at 257 pounds. He had a waist size of 40 inches.
He had a shirt size of double XL and he came
to me looking for a plan to follow. He wanted
to get in shape. He knew he needed some sort
of specific plan and he didn't have one. He
emailed me and said, "Steve, I just picked
up your Rebel Fitness guide." It's a workout
plan that I offer through the website.
He said, "I picked it up. I wanna get started.
I just wanna let you know that today is the
day that I'm starting." All right, Tony. Thanks,
man. I didn't hear from Tony for five months.
I just figured it happens. People drop off
the face of the earth. He tried it, failed,
didn't work out for him. Fortunately, Tony
actually stuck with it.
I got an email from Tony again back in March.
Tony, at this point in March, dropped his
weight down to 211 pounds, which is 46 pounds
lost in five months. His waist size dropped
by four inches. Shirt size went down to large.
The way the Rebel Fitness guide is set up
is it's broken into different levels. For
somebody that's brand new to exercise, you
can start at Level One.
If you do your eight weeks at Level One, then
you progress up to Level Two. As soon as you
get through Level Two, you can move on to
Level Three. So there's this constant progression
and reward system that says, "Hey, you're
able to accomplish this. I encourage you to
move on to the next one."
Well, Tony emailed me in March with his after
picture and said, "Hey, I don't have a Nerd
Fitness t-shirt yet, but as soon as I get
through Level Three, I'm gonna buy one." And
it was so, pretty cool. So Tony actually sent
me a picture wearing his homemade Nerd Fitness
t-shirt, where he had taken his I Heart New
York and taped a blue "F" onto it.
[laughter]
I was so inspired by Tony's story enough that
I said, "If you get through Level Three man,
I'm gonna send you a shirt." And fortunately,
he got through it. So I decided to send him
a Nerd Fitness t-shirt. And on top of that,
what's been great to see is Tony not only
says something like, "Hey, I made it through
Level Three. I can't wait to get to Level
Four."
When he gets to Level Four and beats Level
Four, he said, "I can't wait to move on to
the next Rebel Strength guide." There's another
e-book that I put out. And that was his reward
was to move on to the next step. He wasn't
gonna reward himself by binge eating and drinking
and regressing. He was gonna reward himself
with things that continue to reward him in
the right direction.
So here's a look at Tony again, before and
after. Why was Tony so successful? And I'd
love to say that it was my e-books, but to
be honest with you my e-book is no different
from the other e-books that are offered out
there. It always pretty much comes to the
same thing--having a plan that you can stick
with.
The reason I think my book worked for Tony
is because it's filled with Star Wars and
Lord of the Rings references and things like
that that keep people interested and excited
and have that level progression that Tony
really latched onto. So, he had a specific
plan to follow. Tony started at Level One.
He worked his eight weeks.
As soon as he got through that, he moved on
to Level Two. He did his eight weeks there
and he moved on to Level Three. He's now halfway
through Level Four and as soon as he's done
with that, he said he's gonna move on to the
next e-book, which I told him I'd send him
absolutely free of charge because I just can't
help but love what this guy's been able to
accomplish.
It's been so inspiring for me. And last but
not least, we have our Clans and Competitions.
And this one is relatively self-explanatory.
For this, I mean it's simple. Have a support
group. A lot of us, and I'm assuming at Google
here, you guys have plenty of friends that
are all interested in these type of things.
We're all--.
Here you guys are all work in a similar type
of job. You're sitting behind a desk. You're
sitting at a computer. Maybe you wanna start
getting in shape. So you have those folks
that you can reach out to, folks that you
can express your concerns with and say, "Hey,
I'm not making progress on this," or share
your goals.
And share your successes. If you have an unsupportive
husband or wife and you go home and say, "Honey,
I just dead lifted 225 pounds," and they don't
know what a dead lift is, well, they're probably
not gonna care. And you're not gonna have
that encouragement. So, the reason the thing
about Nerd Fitness that I'm most proud of,
the thing that I think is the future of where
this community is headed is the message board
community and the community itself that has
sprung up around the blog.
The reason I say that is because it's nerds
and desk jockeys from all over the world that
don't have this support group at home. Because
they don't have it at home, they have all
friends that all just wanna sit around and
play video games all day and say, "Hey, you
wanna go exercise?" "No, I'm just gonna sit
here and do this."
Well, they have a support group online--people
that they can reach out to and say, "Hey,
I just did this," or, "I just accomplished
that." And there's thousands. We're up to,
I think, 1700 people on the boards now. So
if anybody posts something like, "Hey, I just
ran my first half marathon," there will be
20 people posting within a couple of minutes
to say congratulations.
And I know that person is so fired up reading
these things and saying, "You know what? I'm
starting to, I get it. I'm part of something
now, something that's bigger than me and I'm
making success. And not only am I being successful,
but I'm inspiring other people to have success
as well." At this point, I wanna introduce
you to my friend Saint.
Saint and I grew up together and we played
basketball back when we were in, I think,
5th grade. And stayed in touch. Actually,
the way Saint and I stayed in touch--. He
lives in Boston and after that, I went to
college in Tennessee, California, and Atlanta.
The way that Saint and I stayed in touch was
really through EverQuest--EverQuest and Gchat
these days.
Saint came to me back in--let's see--it was
January of 2009 and a weight of 236 pounds.
Like any other desk jockey, he had kinda sat
around after he graduated college. Didn't
really keep track of his weight. Didn't really
exercise much. And wanted to start making
some changes. He said, "Steve I wanna lose
weight."
All right, bud. Well, it's somebody that wants
to get in shape. I said, "I encourage you
to start putting some goals in place." Well,
he wasn't really interested in strength training.
He wasn't really interested in keeping track
of what he ate. He's like, "I'll just eat
less and run a lot more." All right. Well,
it's a start. So what happened was Saint lost
about 30 pounds over the course of the year.
Honestly, through the same way that Staci,
or Spezzy, was able to lose her weight by
almost starving himself and running ragged.
So what happened was Saint, back in January,
got all the way down to 203 pounds and then
continued to try and work that weight off.
Unfortunately, over the year nothing happened.
He got stuck at 203 pounds and he ended up
at a body fat percentage around 20% or so,
which is--. He's not a really out of shape
guy. He stayed relatively active, but it wasn't
where he wanted to be. He's always struggled
to get across the 200-pound barrier. And then
something happened that I will always look
back on.
What happened is Saint emailed me out of the
blue, or actually it was on Gchat, back in
January. Said, "Steve, I've made a huge mistake."
"All right, Saint. How much money do you need?"
"No. I don't need any money. I entered into
a competition with my friends at work." "OK.
That sounds like a good idea. Well, what happened?"
"Well, I'm getting married in June and I wanna
be in the best shape of my life for my honeymoon.
So I told my friends that if I didn't get
below ten percent body fat by the time Memorial
Day rolled around, I owe them $500 ." "Saint,
are you an idiot?" "Yes. I'm an idiot." "Do
you have $500 to give to your friends if you
don't make it?"
"No, I don't, which is why I need you to help
me get there." "All right, dude. You got it.
It's gonna be tough, but let's make it happen."
So, over the past five months, I told Saint
he needed to start tracking everything that
he did meticulously if he wanted to get down
to that level. And obviously, ten percent
is a really low number.
So he had to be incredibly diligent with not
only what he ate, but how he trained. And
obviously, decent genetics and everything
like that factored in there as well. But he
started to--. He wanted to get down to that
body fat percentage. So this is Saint's weight
over the past five months. If you notice,
he started up around 203 pounds.
He quickly weight dropped off. He lost seven
pounds or so right around the February mark.
Weight went down a little bit. Went down around
to 193 pounds. And then his weight started
going back up again. So by the time middle
of May rolled around, Saint had only lost
seven pounds. Fortunately, Saint had been
tracking a lot of other metrics as well.
So for the past five months, Saint has been
tracking his body fat percentage by getting
it measured every two weeks. He also took
measurements of different parts of his body
every two weeks to make sure he was progressing
in the right direction. So after a month and
a half, Saint's body fat, although his weight
was dropping as we saw in the previous slide,
his body fat wasn't going anywhere.
And he's like, "Oh, crap. Well, I'm two months
in. I got three months to go. I don't have
$500 to give up. I need to start making some
changes." So I told Saint, "All right, man.
What you need to do is focus on getting stronger.
Put the focus on getting stronger. We're gonna
clean up your diet." That day, he signed up
for a gym membership and started lifting heavy.
Like clockwork, Saint's body fat dropped back
in March. Actually, he started joining the
gym right around mid-February. He went from
right around 20 percent in mid-February all
the way down to nine point five percent in
May. He emailed me halfway through May and
said, "Holy crap. I did it." "What did you
do?"
He said, "I got down to nine point five percent."
"All right." Well again, this is one of those
situations where I wouldn't believe it if
I didn't see it. This is Saint back in January.
And this is Saint in May. Again, and when
I say January. The weight really didn't start
dropping off until halfway through February.
The reason Saint was able to have the success
is 'cause he had that fire lit underneath
him.
I'm not encouraging everyone to start betting
their friends that they pay them 500 bucks
so they don't get what they want, but it was
able for them--. It was a way for Saint to
finally start making some changes. Not only
did he make these changes, but he put his
focus on getting stronger. Saint leveled up
his life by focusing on getting stronger.
And the best part about this whole thing is
I get emails from Saint, Gchats from Saint
on a daily basis still. Whereas for the past
two years, they'd always been, "I need to
lose weight," or, "I can't get to where I
need to be," or, "I can't do this." These
Gchats are now, "Holy crap, Steve. I just
dead lifted 225 pounds for the first time."
"Steve, I can do five pull-ups in a row now.
Last year, I couldn't do a single pull-up."
Or, "Hey, I just dunked a basketball. I didn't
think I'd ever be able to do that." But he
did it. His goals have now completely shifted.
They've gone from "I need to lose weight,"
something generic to something super specific.
He wanted to get to a certain body fat percentage.
That was his driving force to begin with.
And since then, his goals have shifted to
wanting to become stronger and a more leveled
up version of himself. And that's what all
three of these folks have in common. They
all set specific, concrete goals. Not only
did they have these specific, concrete goals,
but they broke these goals down into specific
steps.
So they knew what they needed to do to go
from Level One to Level Two to Level Three.
There was always that progression. It was
never too overwhelming for them 'cause all
they had to focus on was that next logical
step of the progression. On top of that, they
all tracked their workouts.
They tracked their weight and multiple other
things on themselves to make sure they were
headed in the right direction. If Saint wasn't
tracking his body fat and he just saw that
his weight was dropping off, he wasn't taking
measurements, he never would've known that--.
He wasn't sure why things weren't working
out for him, but because he was keeping track
of all these different things and he could
compare them week over week, month over month,
he could see that progress and say, "OK. I'm
there. I'm starting to do things in the right
way. I'm making progress. I can build on this."
Last but not least, they all incorporated
community. I can guarantee you--. Community
and competition. I can guarantee you, Staci
wouldn't look the way she does today if she
had never found the Nerd Fitness community
that helped her find her love of barbell training
and really enjoying strength training. I can
tell you Saint would still be stuck at 203
pounds today if he didn't have that competition
behind him to finally push him over the edge
and wanna start making some serious changes.
And I'll tell you just a quick, little bit
about my epic quest. Back in December, I was
living with two friends in Atlanta. And one
is moving in with his girlfriend. And another
one is moving out of state. So I had this
opportunity as well. I could get my own place
to live and keep doing what I'm doing. I had
already been running Nerd Fitness as my full-time
job for the past six months.
Or, I could book some crazy trip. And the
reason I wanted to book a crazy trip is because
honestly, I'm one of the most risk-adverse
homebodies that you'll meet. Up until November
of last year, I had never been out of North
America. I am a very picky eater. So, traveling
to foreign countries scared the crap out of
me.
And things that scared me, I told myself,
"How are you going to encourage people to
want to live better and step outside of their
comfort zone if you can't do it yourself?"
So for me, I essentially travel-hacked. I
sold my car. Sold most of my stuff. And travel-hacked
my way into a 35,000 mile trip around the
world.
I wanted to start crossing things off my bucket
list. Now, obviously a bucket list doesn't
sound nerdy enough, so I decided to call it
my Epic Quest of Awesome, 'cause I thought
it sounded cooler. So, while traveling, I
started doing things that scared me when visiting
a foreign country. Here I am doing push-ups
on the Great Wall of China.
Bungee jumping. Scuba-diving with sharks and
finding Nemo down there. And even jumping
out of an airplane. I started doing things
that really scared me because I not only wanted
to level up my workouts and my fitness, but
I wanted to level up my life. And for me to
level up my life, it was doing things and
seeing things and experiencing things that
I had never seen or done or felt before.
It also presented an interesting situation
for me. I've been a gym rat, I guess, for
the past decade of my life. I can think of
maybe three or four months along the way where
I haven't had a gym membership. And in those
three or four months, I've gotten weaker because
I didn't know what the heck to do if I didn't
have barbells and plates and all that good
stuff to workout.
So, I had to put a plan in place. Honestly,
it was for you guys. I wanted to come back
to Google in better shape than when I left.
So I was scared I was gonna come back after
four months of living out of a backpack, no
gym, looking like a complete skeleton and
having you guys saying, "Who the heck is this
guy and who is he to tell us about fitness?"
So I spent the three months while traveling,
I'm sorry, three and a half months while traveling,
no gym, living out of a backpack, completely
readjusting how I worked out. And to do that,
I put my focus on getting stronger with only
body weight exercises. And that was a concept
that I just honestly didn't think was possible.
I can do push-ups, but I don't think that's
gonna get me any stronger, if I keep doing
the same kind of push-ups in a row. So I started
doing research into guys like gymnasts and
people from Cirque du Soleil. I figured, "You
know what? If these guys can get in great
shape without picking up a weight, maybe I
could, too."
On top of that, a term I like to use is "MacGyvering"
a workout. I'm sure everybody has seen the
show MacGyver, where MacGyver, he's save the
world or blow up something that if you give
him a paper clip, a piece of gum, and a plastic
straw, and he'll figure out a way to make
a bomb out of it. Well, for me, I had to figure
a way how to make a workout out of everywhere
that I was traveling.
So every time I got out into a new city, I
would walk around until I found either a tree
branch, a kid's swing set, overhang of a bus
station. I've even worked out hanging off
of something inside the Auckland, New Zealand
airport because that was where I could find
something to do pull-ups on. And beyond those
pull-ups, everything else I did was just using
my body weight.
And along with just using the body weight
exercises, I had to clearly defined path for
success. And what I mean by that is there
was a logical progression for each exercise
that I had to go through in order for me to
actually get to that successful stage. And
what I mean by that is I started out doing
regular push-ups.
As soon as those became too easy for me, I
knew where to go next. I put my feet up on
a bench and do decline push-ups. From there,
I started working towards handstand push-ups,
where I just put my feet up against a wall
and try to hold a handstand as long as possible.
From there, trying to do maybe a half handstand
push-up.
Beyond that, doing a full handstand push-up.
I'm at the point know where I can do nine
handstand push-ups in a row, something that
I hadn't even considered five months ago.
It's something I never even thought I'd be
able to do just because it wasn't something
I'd considered. On top of that, I can now
do--.
I went from doing seven pull-ups in a row
to 20 pull-ups in a row. And from zero one-legged
squats, I can almost do five on each leg now.
And as a result of getting stronger and doing
these things, I put a focus on eating healthier.
As a result, I put on ten pounds in the past
three months of almost all muscle while living
out of a backpack and traveling.
And I realized, "You know what? If I can do
this while traveling, there's no reason that
nobody else can not build a workout." And
here at Google, you guys have such a great
advantage. You guys have personal trainers
on staff that can help you out if you're interested.
You have people that can answer your questions.
But there's sometimes where maybe you're traveling
or on vacation and you wanna get in shape
and you don't really know where to begin.
Well, you can really break things down to
make things as simple as possible. As they
say, "Keep it simple, stupid." So, in order
to build a workout, I like to keep everything
at 45 minutes--no longer than that.
Be super intense in those 45 minutes. And
also, focus on doing real world movements.
And by that, I mean doing exercises that prepare
your body for the real world. I don't mean
doing bicep curls and getting in a machine
and doing leg curls and all that garbage.
I mean doing things that actually help you
out while you're traveling.
I mean, help you out in your real life. And
for that, I mean if you can do a simple body
weight squat and drop down below--. Drop your
body down and focus on squats. The next time
you need to move your couch, pick up your
kid, grab your groceries, your body is already
prepared for these movements because you've
put your body through these movements on a
repeated basis.
It's ready to handle these things. So if it's
ready to handle these things, you're gonna
be far less likely inclined to get injured.
On top of that, you can also pick your exercise,
I'm sorry. Pick your level for each exercise.
And by that, I mean for a push-up. You go
from a push-up to a declined push-up, to that
next level.
Each push-up is going up. Squats can go from
two-legged squats to one-legged squats while
holding on to something, down to--. There
are huge--. There's levels and levels of progressions
for each exercise you can do. So for this,
I made things super simple for while I was
traveling 'cause I knew I wouldn't have a
lot of time.
I might be at a bus station one day, the next
day in a different town. So I wanted to keep
things super simple. I started with a simple
push exercise. By that, I mean push-ups. If
you can't do a single push-up yet, you can
start by doing them against a wall, putting
your hands on the side of a bench, something
where it makes it a little easier for you.
Just like the rest of your life, you can level
it up step by step by step until you're getting
stronger. After you do your push exercises,
we move on to a pull exercise. Pull is gonna
work your back, your biceps and your forearms.
So right there you've pretty much covered
almost every single muscle group in your entire
upper body in two exercises.
Now, you might be able to do a pull-up. You
might not. If you can't do a pull-up, it's
OK. There are progressions you can take on
pull-ups as well, whether it's a bent over
row where you're down on one knee, lifting
your backpack, your laptop bag, something
up in the air, pulling backwards. That is
working your back and will get you started
in the right direction towards finally doing
a pull-up.
After that, we have leg exercises. This is
simple. Squats, lunges, anything that involves
your lower body. If you squat deep enough,
not only are you activating your quads, but
you're also activating your hamstrings, your
flutes, your calves. Your whole lower body
essentially gets worked out along with your
core.
When you're doing things like squats and lunges
and you can do things called step ups, where
you're stepping up onto a high ledge, or doing
box jumps where you're jumping up onto a ledge.
It's putting your entire lower body through
a workout in just one exercise. Last but not
least we have our core exercise.
It's gonna work your stomach, your lower back,
and your obliques. So just like that in four
exercises, we've almost covered every muscle
group in your body. And I understand this
is not a fully complete workout, but if you're
pinched for time, if you're traveling, if
you don't have a gym, you don't have weights
to lift, or maybe you're just not interested
in going to a gym.
To be honest with you, I might never have
set foot in a gym again because I've had so
much fun doing what I've done over these past
four months. And you take these four exercises.
Now I realize this chart looks a little intimidating
at first. But it really is very similar to
a Choose Your Own Adventure. I remember reading
those books as a kid.
What you take is you have your four exercises
from the previous page and you decide on what
your desired outcome is. If you want to build
strength, you simply focus on only doing four
to six reps. If you want to hypertrophy, which
is essentially increasing muscular size, you're
gonna focus on doing eight to twelve reps.
And maybe you wanna focus on muscular endurance,
if you're an endurance athlete or you just
wanna see how much of a certain exercise you
can do. That's when your reps are gonna go
from 12 to 15 plus. So what you're gonna do,
is you take your four exercises--it's almost
like fill in the equation--you pick your four
exercises.
You decide on your sets, your reps, and your
rests. And then you track your results. You
say, "I did four sets of ten push-ups this
week. I did three sets of five squats this
week. And I did four sets of two pull-ups."
Perfect. Write it down. Pull up Evernote on
your phone or shoot yourself an email. Keep
track of what you did this week so next week
you know exactly what you need to do in order
to be better.
And I realize that's a very simplified version
of what a workout is. I also make sure you
warm up beforehand and stretch properly afterwards.
I didn't want to get into all that stuff here
in this presentation. It would take way too
long. I actually love to work with the Google
trainers here and send everybody that's interested
a .pdf of not only what I've been doing on
the past four months with descriptions and
videos of each exercise, but also a unified
message between Nerd Fitness and Google.
I don't think there's a better audience that
I can get in front of as far as being a nerd
and being excited about fitness. And putting
together something that you guys can not only
take with you, but read and kinda start building
your own concepts. It's very similar to the
whole give a man a fish, he eats for a day.
Teach a man to fish, he eats for a lifetime,
blah, blah, blah.
You know it. It's very similar to that. So,
today I wanna leave you with one final concept
before we open up to questions. It comes down
to "Do something. Do anything." We're all
at that point in our lives where certain things
seem overwhelming. If you're really overweight
and you wanna get down to a certain weight,
it could be very overwhelming and intimidating.
If you wanna go to a gym and it's scary for
you to get there, don't worry. Maybe you wanna
finally you run a marathon, but you can't
walk ten feet without losing your breath.
That's OK. Focus on doing something today.
And by that, it can honestly mean as something
as walking a little bit, doing a couple push-ups
at your desk in-between sets.
I'm sorry, in between projects. And maybe
you're trying to eat better. Focus on changing
one thing in your diet, trying to eat a little
bit healthier. And the example I always like
to call upon is--just to cement my nerdiness--I
like to look back and think about Optimus
Prime from Transformers.
When you think of Optimus Prime, you got this
huge Mack Truck, and all of a sudden he becomes
a freaking giant robot. How did he do it?
One step at a time. It wasn't he snapped his
fingers and all of a sudden transformed from
a truck into a robot. One tire pulled in.
The windshield pulls down a little bit. Something
else gets tucked behind something else.
And little by little, step by step, Optimus
Prime transforms himself literally, from a
Mack Truck into a robot. So, I encourage you
to start doing something. Build on that. And
once you're doing something, get a little
bit better at it each time and you'll start
to see some results and hopefully start leveling
up your life.
I guess we open up to questions now. Before
I get there, I just wanna say again guys,
thank you so much for coming out. It's been
an absolute pleasure to be here at Google
and probably one of the coolest things I've
ever done. I actually added this to my Epic
Quest. I finally crossed this off today. So
thank you again for having me.
[applause]
I don't know if anybody has any questions.
Maybe, maybe not. I guess not. Yes. Sure.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: [ inaudible ]
>>Steve Kamb: You know, it's funny you should
mention--. My dad, actually, growing up, my
dad--. I'm sorry.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: [ inaudible ]
>>Steve Kamb: Oh, sure. The questions was
thank you for reminding me. The question was
a question about my parents and what my parents
have done since before starting Nerd Fitness
and since then. Is that what you mean? Or
like growing up and--.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: Growing up and
then [ inaudible ].
>>Steve Kamb: OK. So, growing up and through
then.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: [ inaudible].
>>Steve Kamb: Sure. Absolutely. So, my parents
were never overweight. Never, never really
overweight, but they both worked desk jobs
so they all had the same thing over the course
of 20, 30 years of sitting behind a desk.
My dad developed a little bit of a gut, like
every other guy that generally works at a
desk and spends all his time there. And I
never told him to make any changes. And this
is actually something that I have really come
to enjoy. I wanna say my dad is a big guy.
He's six five. He weighs, I think at his biggest
he was probably 230, maybe 240.
But he hadn't exercised in years up until
I started Nerd Fitness. And I never told him
to make a change, but his diet wasn't the
cleanest. And he wasn't exercising a lot.
And I was actually worried about him. I want
my dad to be around forever, like everybody
does. And I was kind of worried about him.
But my dad has been such an important figure
in my life, that how do you bring up something
to your dad and say, "Hey dad. I need you
to start losing weight." And I didn't. Instead,
I chose to try to inspire him through my actions.
And by that, I mean I never once brought up,
"Hey Dad, you need to lose weight."
It was more, "Hey Dad. Check out this article
I read." Or he made sure he was reading Nerd
Fitness every day since then. I'd been very,
very lucky to have supportive parents throughout
this whole thing. And since then, my dad has
actually been able to lose--I wanna say--between
20 and 30 pounds through nothing I've requested,
but he started doing push-ups and started
cleaning up his diet.
And it's been cool to see that he emailed
me and said, "Hey, I've lost 12 pounds this
year and I'm gonna lose another 12 next year."
Wow. Dad, that's awesome. I didn't ask it
of him, but I really wanted it for him. So
it's been cool to see that progression happen.
Same thing with my mom and also my sister.
My sister actually started strength training
along with the Rebel Strength guide.
It's the e-book I put out a couple months
back. And I saw a picture of her the other
day. And I haven't seen her since I left for
my trip. Holy crap. You look great. And my
sister, what she'd been doing, she'd been
strength training. She emailed me the other
day and said, "Holy crap Steve. I did two
pull-ups."
And this is my younger sister, who had never
been able to do a pull-up in her life. She
said, "Hey Steve. I can finally do two pull-ups."
And that's awesome. Go for three. So now,
my family has started to embrace this stuff
through not because I've asked them to, but
because they've been inspired. But not only
what I've written about, but inspired by these
stories and the people that have started popping
up in the blogs and in the message boards
and stuff like that.
So, my folks were never overweight, but they
were very typical Americans with a desk job.
A gut to lose and some weight to drop and
something they never considered focusing on
until Nerd Fitness finally started happening.
Yes.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: I have a nerdy
question.
>>Steve Kamb: A nerdy question, yes. Absolutely.
I love it.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: Any particular
tools you'd want a person to look at for tracking
and reporting progress?
>>Steve Kamb: Absolutely. Tools that I recommend.
The question was any nerdy tools out there
to recommend for progress? The best thing
that I found as far as keeping things digital
was a website called dailyburn.com.
And what it is, it's just a simple program
for you to keep track of what you're eating
and your workouts. And you can put your weights
every time you measure it. And every time
you weigh in, you put your weights in there.
And the reason I found it so great is because
when I wanted to start building muscle, I
realized I wasn't eating enough.
And for most people that wanna start losing
weight, they don't realize that they're eating
too much. So I encourage them to sign up for
Daily Burn. Spend two to three days tracking
their calories. And really keeping track of--.
And the reason Daily Burn makes it so easy
is you can simply type in something like "strawberries"
or "Kit-Kat" or whatever.
And it provides all statistics for it--the
carbs, grams of sugar, total calories, everything.
And at the end of the day, you can look at
it and go, "Wow. I didn't realize I ate that
much." Or, "Wow. I didn't realize I wasn't
eating enough or was eating enough protein
and etc." And then on top of that as far as
tracking workouts, I love to use a program
called Evernote.
It's a simple app for my phone. And I'm sure
many of you have it where I just pull-up a
document. I put the title and it'll say, "5/31,"
or "6/01" will say Mountain View, California.
And I'll write down what I did. I started
out with a dynamic warm up and jump roped
for five minutes to get my blood pumping.
Then I did this many push-ups with 90 seconds
in-between each set.
And then I did this many push-ups, so very
basic. I don't--. You can track it on Excel,
if you're interested. If people wanna be more--.
Or Google Docs if you wanna be, keep in the
cloud like that. But for me, Evernote worked
out great 'cause I knew it would email it,
or I could--. It would live in infinity. And
for me while traveling, I didn't have internet
while traveling.
All I had was Wi-Fi if I could find it here
and there. So my iPhone pretty much became
a glorified iPod for four months while traveling,
so I never used the 3G service on it. So more
me, Evernote worked out great 'cause I could
go track a workout, go back to the hostel
or hotel I was staying in and it would upload
my document to Evernote so I could keep track
of each of my workouts and compare them to
previous workouts.
On top of that, there is a thing called an
Accu-Measure 3000, to measure your body fat
percentage. Now, this is one of those things
where the most accurate methods are also some
of the most expensive. You could do the hydrostatic
testing, where they float you in a tub, or
they put you in a room where they can pressurize
the air and they can figure out your body
fat percentage.
For most people, that's just not realistic.
And it's also not something they're interested
in doing. So, you can pick up one of these
body fat calipers for, I think it's like ten
bucks online. And it's relatively accurate.
And the thing that's important about it is
it might be off by a percentage point or two,
compared to the super complex advanced thing,
like the hydrostatic testing.
But as long as you're testing yourself in
the same spot and using the same tool on a
bi-weekly basis, you can see that progress
is changing. So, I use an Accu-Measure body
fat tester. And then also, just a simple tape
measure. They have ones that you just wrap
around your arms. You can take measurements
of your chest, your navel, your waist, your
hips, your thighs, to see if the weight is
coming off in the right spots.
For most guys, they wanna keep the weight
up on their shoulders and chest, and lose
it down in their gut. So, if you're taking
measurements and you know it's coming off
in the right spots and you're tracking those
things. So, I'd say a combination of those
four things, super basic. You can get a tape
measure for three bucks.
Evernote is free and the body fat caliper,
which is tiny. It's this big. You pinch yourself,
you read a chart, put your age in, and it's
relatively accurate. So between those things,
you spent 15 bucks, you can track yourself
on a daily basis, or bi-weekly basis, depending
on what you're interested in doing to get
some results out of it.
So, those are the four I do recommend. One
more. Yes, sir. Go ahead. And I'll stick around
for as long as you guys want, if you wanna
talk after this, for sure.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: [ inaudible ]
>>Steve Kamb: Yes.
>>Steve Kamb: Mm-hmm.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: I'm wondering [ inaudible
].
>>Steve Kamb: You know, it depends. From what
I found--. Oh, to repeat the question people.
The question was, do people, as Staci started
taking on strength training, do you see a
lot of guys start taking on aerobic activity?
And to be honest with you, I think most people
that's the natural progression, is they start
with the aerobic stuff because that's the
easiest thing for them to grasp. They don't
have a gym membership. They don't know how
to exercise, so the easiest thing for them
to do is to put on a pair of running shoes
and go for a walk.
So, they always start with the exercise and
maybe counting calories and making a couple
adjustments there. There's definitely plenty
of folks that read Nerd Fitness that don't
do any sort of strength training, but they
love to run. I try to push them towards strength
training 'cause I'm personally biased. I think
that's such an important part of getting in
shape.
But there are plenty of folks that are in
great shape that run marathons that don't
strength train that do that aerobic cardio
stuff. Absolutely. And as far as girls go,
I think, I'm actually hoping to highlight
Staci more on the blog because she has such
a great story to encourage more girls to wanna
start strength training, to show that you're
not gonna get bulky and big, which is the
issue that all girls have.
They pick up their five-pound pink dumbbells
and do bicep curls 'cause they're scared of
getting too big. I'll tell you, Staci is dead
lifting 315 pounds, putting weight on, and
looking better than she's ever looked before,
in better shape, healthier, happier than she's
ever been before. So I think there's gonna
be a lot more crossover from the girls, hopefully
to the strength training.
And not even just weights, but maybe even
body weight type stuff. That's something they're
getting into while still supplementing that
with running and things that still make them
happy. If somebody runs, I don't tell them
to stop running. If it makes them happy, by
all means, do it. The best exercise plan is
something that you're actually going to follow.
So if you hate strength training and you love
running, by all means keep running. If you
hate running and love strength training, keep
strength training. Don't--. Put you're focus
on the stuff that you love and you'll find
a way to find some success with it. And I
think we're out of time. So guys, thanks.
Everybody up there watching, thank you.
And I guess we'll see you later. I am gonna
stick around for a while if anybody wants
to talk. And I guess we'll go from there.
So, thanks.
[applause]